TC39 Panel
>> Hello!
Welcome, everyone!
Random enthusiasm!
Wow.
! [Cheering].
That is better than the last break.
I don't know whether you had more cake and
coffee, but this is really great.
This is a new format to JSConf and I'm excited
about this.
I think it is going to be great.
I personally didn't know what TC39 was and
now I do and I'm excited.
If you're wondering how JavaScript gets standardised,
how they are making those calls and how you
can get involved, this is the right session
to be at.
I will invite quite a few people to the stage,
and I hope they do something cool because
I can't, I don't have the dance skills!
I will invite, Maggie be Miles James, Dan
and Dominic to the stage.
Please give them a warm welcome.
[Applause].
This exciting discussion will be moderated
by Elia.
You can ask questions on Twitter.
We're about to have an insightful discussion
about how JavaScript will be built.
JULIA: I hope everyone is doing well after
the cake and that was great.
Thank you so much to the people who have agreed
to be on the panel.
We have James at the end, there, Dominic,
Jan, Miles, and Maggie.
Does everyone with their mic on?
>> Yes.
>> Hello.
JULIA: this is going to be really exciting!
I think the question that a lot of people,
if they haven't about TC39, the first time
they saw it on the schedule.
They are going to be wondering what is this.
Who would like to take that on?
>> TC39 is the standards committee that defines
JavaScript, so it's been around basically
as long, long as the language as been.
We meet every month.
This is the group that designed ES6 and designing
async 08.
The spec is designed on GitHub.
>> The other thing is TC39 works on JavaScript
standardisation which is distinct from web
standardisation which is done by other standards
orgs, so a lot of the APIs that you use, mayor
not you're not.
People aren't sure session time out is a web
API.
The things in the JavaScript are small - we're
focused on language features, small syntax
and core library.
JULIA: one thing that I heard is that JavaScript
is really a standalone language, used on the
web, but it is really like something you can
use anywhere.
And one thing that people can be interested
in is what is a standard, actually?
What does that mean?
>> Standard is just a document that describes
what is - what a certain thing is, what is
supposed to happen when you execute some code
in the example of a programming language.
A standard really takes relevance when it
corresponds to implementations, when it's
a design that everyone agrees on, and that
people can actually take advantage of.
There are lots of standards that you can find
if you search around, and some of them are
outdated, and some of them were just fantasy.
I think that the JavaScript standard that
TC39 produced does a really good job of striking
a balance between continuing to add new things
and also maintaining relevance through certain
processes.
>> The term "standard" tends to be overused
in a lot of contexts.
It's essentially a document that describes
the way something should happen.
It is not necessarily - it doesn't necessarily
describe the way things actually happen, the
way the implementers have done it.
It is the set-up rules, if you're going to
do this, do it like this.
>> The other cool thing about JavaScript,
having a standard and having a pretty solid
one, is this is unusual among a lot of languages.
Languages - I hope I'm not inaccurate here
- but Ruby and Python do not have the standard,
they have the original implementation.
Everyone who wants to have something compatible
with those reverse-engineers it.
Maybe this is okay for a server, or a mostly
server language, but for something where we
have four competing implementations at least
in the browser and elsewhere, it is really
important to have a central document that
says everybody should be working the same
way.
JULIA: something that is particularly unique
about JavaScript's standard is that the standard
leads the language, so the C# programming
language - I work for Microsoft, I have tonnes
of interaction with .NET, they make the standard
after they create the programming language,
and, in JavaScript, we have the opposite happening:
we create the standard and then the engines
pick it up and implement it.
So that's a very unusual characteristic that
has to do with the nature of the web.
JULIA: I think it is interesting that you
said you're working with Microsoft.
On the TC39 which stands to have "technical
committee 39" you're representing the JS Foundation,
right?
Can you talk a bit about how you got involved
in the committee and also representing the
group that you do.
>> Sure, so, one thing everyone should know
is that some people up on this stage do have
academic backgrounds in language design and
extensive work there, but that's not like
a requirement for TC39.
For me, I am a very average full stack web
developer for Microsoft.
I work in crisis management.
It has nothing to do with language design
at all.
I'm nowhere near the language design teams
at Microsoft, and I maintain Moment.js, the
daytime library.
What I found Moment exists is because the
date functionality in JavaScript is very bad,
and I started like running around Microsoft
when I first starting working there a year
ago, and I was like, "Does anybody care?
Is anybody going to fix the date?
Still broken!"
And nobody - I wouldn't say nobody did - in
fact, Brian Charleston's who is Microsoft's
representative to TC39, he was like, "I care
a lot about that."
When we found each other, he was like, "Let's
get this done."
I had to find a way to get there.
The JS Foundation again is a open-source foundation
that supports the needs of many of the major
open-source libraries in the JavaScript ecosystem,
to all of the jQuery is under JS Foundation,
Lowe Dash Grunt Webpack, they said if you
care so much about this standard, we can send
you to go and represent our libraries.
That's how I ended up there.
JULIA: thank you.
We have some people who have been working
on the committee for like varying periods
of time, so Maggie you've recently joined,
and we also have Dominic who has been part
of TC39 for a few years.
Can you talk about your experience joining
and what was TC39 like before?
>> Yes, it is kind of funny to think - I guess
I'm one of the people who has been on the
committee longest in the panel.
There's a lot of new faces, so I still feel
like I'm relatively new.
There are a lot of people who are the committee
and very well established.
My story: I was a web developer using JavaScript.
I got kind of involved in the language just
through curiosity.
I was like, "Oh, I learned about all these
new features, when are they coming?
What is the deal?
I hear Firefox has let and const why aren't
they in the language?"
One area I really got involved in was asynchronous
APIs and promises, and there was a push to
put these in the web platform somehow either
through the DOM APIs or the language.
I thought it would work well in the language.
There was a meeting in Boston.
I took some time off work and got the bus
up from New York.
I presented my written-up fairly formal spec
on how Promises should work in JavaScript,
and the committee was like, "This is pretty
good.
Let's get this into ES6."
So that was just the beginning of a long journey
and a lot of arguments committee and -
>> Many arguments!
>> And Promises was certainly not without
controversy.
I think they've been pretty successful, and
after - I stayed involved, I did in - this
a lot in my free time, got involved in other
web standards.
Google hired me to represent in TC39 and do
this full-time.
That was my journey.
>> That's pretty great.
JULIA: I just want to touch super quickly,
you're talking about getting features in the
spec.
Can you say a bit about that process?
Where do you start and what steps do you go
through to get something into the spec?
>> Yes, so there is a whole formal process,
but to boil it down to its essentials, the
first step is explain the feature, explain
what it would look like by developers, what
need would it address?
Does it exist in other languages?
What cross-cutting concerns might there be
across the other languages that exist?
Generally, it is convincing people this is
a good idea and your solution to the problem
is to solve the problem.
Then you advance through the stages of increasingly
formalising your proposal, writing actual
spec text, and bringing it to the committee,
and getting it increasingly checked and solidified
along the way.
>> There is a multistage proposal.
In order to advance to the next step, there
has to be a certain amount of implementation
experience.
It advances, the spec needs to reflect what
is actually implemented, so that way, when
it comes out of the other end, you know it
actually matches what users are going to be
using out in the world.
>> That's somewhat new.
ES6 was the speck that led the implementations.
Now they are more intent on, which is very
healthy, but I can go through this a lot but
I won't.
JULIA: we have the won September of a champion.
Maggie, can you speak about that at all?
>> Sure, so the whole, I guess, reason that
I ended up at TC39 at all, which actually
is a lot big like knowledge Nick's reason
which is I heard a heck of of a lot about
one thing.
For the moment, I am the champion or the person
who is responsible for moving forward the
fixing of dates.
In the language.
I share that responsibility with Brian at
Microsoft, and to get a proposal moved forward
through the process, you have to find someone
willing to champion that proposal.
Now, many people on TC39 represent browser
implementers or other large corporations,
so we have a few people from Google here.
In my case, I actually would be the person
who would represent you, because I represent
the JS Foundation which is basically we think
of ourselves as the community at large, but
to get a proposal through, you need to find
a champion, and that would be the person who
represents you as part of your organisation,
Microsoft, Mozilla, Google, et cetera, or
if you don't have a larger organisation direct,
then come find me or Leo Walter.
JULIA: awesome.
Those are things that are on development right
now that each of you are super excited about.
What is the most exciting thing coming up
in the next spec?
What is in development right now?
>> For me, it is not necessarily what's coming
up soon, it is what already was developed,
and that's modules, right?
I've been working very hard with some of the
folks in the Node community to get modules
into Node, and they are coming.
It is going to take a long time, but they
are coming.
But, yes, that is the thing I'm most excited
about seeing advance.
>> Yeah, like James, coming from the browser
perspective, I also am spending a lot of time
getting modules.
We put out the syntax for them in ES6 but
no semantics, so saying modules in ES6 is
not really true in a large sense.
So we're finally getting to that point.
I spend a lot of time on that.
I've also worked on shared array buffer which
is the subject of an upcoming talk.
We had a lot of fun.
It is similar in that it needs to integrate
into the web platform.
We need to say what threads can you share
this array buffer between?
It's not a question for the language but a
thing that defines the threads, the web workers
and web platform.
Finally, I'm also championing a proposal called
async adderation.
>> A smaller thing I'm working on is features
for regular expressions.
This allows to you do things like reference
unicode categories for characters in a regular
expression, or also give names to groups that
are being captured, and a couple of other
things.
I'm definitely excited about that, and the
implementation is in V8 behind a flag, and
I'm also work on a specification for arbitrary
sized images in JavaScript with operator overloading.
[Applause].
Also some features for classes.
I'm definitely interested in getting more
feedback from this whole group on all these.
>> Work on the big instep before the classes.
>> So, what I'm most excited about right now
is not a feature of the language, but I will
call it a feature of the committee.
There is a lot of work going on right now
for a code of conduct within TC39, and that
is interesting because many code of conducts
are about conduct of a community, which is
very different than conduct of a committee,
so it is interesting to try to reconcile the
differences between this and find the language
that works, but it is being put through the
process, and I would say, I've only been to
three meetings, but I've seen the conduct
change just with this being on the table.
>> I suppose it is obvious I'm excited about
date!
[Laughter].
I will - I do want to mention, along with
the 262 specification for the JavaScript programming
language, TC39 handles 402 which is the internationalisation
APIs coming from the date/time space, this
stuff is really important.
I'm really excited for everything that is
going on in Intel because it will really help
people produce more global applications.
JULIA: we also have a number of questions,
so we out - so we sourced a number of people
from you people, the community through this
hashtag, and I'm going to read out a couple
of them.
Unfortunately, the panel is very short, because
like all of these topics are fascinating and
could be a talk all on their own.
We selected a couple of those questions that
we could answer in the time that we have and
I'm just going to ask a couple of them now.
One of the questions we were asked is what
is the state of the binder operator, and what
needs to be done to advance it?
That came from Tobias.
>> I think I can take this.
The bind operator is a fairly popular proposal:
briefly, the idea combines several ideas into
one.
You want this method-change syntax so you
can define things in another library but use
them as if they're methods on an existing
library, so in other languages, this might
be called extension methods, or something
like that, and this is a pretty great idea
because then you could define something like
low dash but use it as if it were on a native
array as if they were methods.
It also gives you syntactic sugar for binding
and extracting methods, and a number of other
things, and there are variants of this.
There is a pipeline operator where the bind
operator uses this, the pipeline operator
uses the first argument like low dash.
The problem that it's this complicated space
with a lot of decisions about, "Well, do we
really want to tie it to this or the first
argument?
Do we really want to tie binding into the
story?
Or do we really want to make it more general?"
Every time somebody's tried to pick this up,
there's so many people who feel the opposite
way, largely in the community.
The committee I think would be open to anything
if we had a clear signal from the community,
in my perspective.
It has been discouraging trying to get it
moving forward.
The other thing is we just - you know, well,
we have had champions, but I think they've
gotten discouraged.
I don't know if that's fair in Dan's estimation?
>> I would just want to phrase, reiterate
by saying this is a big opportunity for saying
this is a big involvement for - opportunity
for community involvement and it is a positive.
The committee is definitely interested in
this proposal once we have more of these kind
of signals.
>> Standards are that are made without community
involvement are not good standards, period.
[Applause].
JULIA: that's a very good point, because there
is sort of an issue with that how many people
know about this committee, and they don't
know how to get involved with it, and this
is also an opportunity for us to get more
people involved.
James, I'm actually going to direct this at
you because you mentioned modules, and someone
has asked, "What is the status of ES Interrupt
- module interrupt" and it's been raised many
times, and they're wondering what the status
is.
>> This is an area where the browsers are
ahead of Node.
There's still some variance in the browser
and Dominic could speak to that better than
than I could.
As far as Node implementation, we're a long
way off - until at least a year until the
community has something to work with.
We're going to get there.
There is a lot more issues on the servers
than on the Node side, that the browsers just
don't have to deal with, so it is a lot, it
is a very difficult technical problem.
Once we get there, I think by the time we
get there, the browsers will be like, "What
took you so long?"
We will be able to ensure pretty good interrupt,
but, yeah.
>> Yeah, from the browser side, we're trying
to do as much as we can to iron out the bugs
in the underlying infrastructure, so that
when Node is able to tackle it, we can say,
"Okay, it's ready for you."
Again it's just this multi-year process.
First we had module syntax and how module
for the browser.
Semantics are bolt-proof until you have them
working in two environments.
It's not a great interface.
It's tough.
>> A big challenge here also is that Ecma
262 only defines the semantics for models
but not for loading.
There are different constraints.
So the browser can't block the main thread
while it's loading everything, so you have
only like this asynchronous load phase before
asynchronous execute operation, whereas the
way Require works is synchronous execution
through the whole tree when it's the loading.
This isn't - we can reconcile this, but it
is just - it breaks my brain and many people's
brains.
It takes a lot of time to find a way to do
it that allows both the code in the browser
and in Node to run similarly.
What we want to avoid is a case where you
need to start worrying is, is it running in
Node or in a browser?
>> I published a couple of articles of this
on Medium.
There's likely to be another one in a couple
of months.
So, small hint!
That will give a pretty good update.
This is a whole topic that can take a long
time to discuss.
>> Please subscribe to the news letter.
JULIA: another question: will you drop any
features from JavaScript?
>> I will take this.
So, with come the Node perspective, just looking
at Node, just looking at Node, every time
we want to deprecate something or drop something,
there are pitch forks and we have to go running.
Imagine that on the language level.
Probably not.
>> Yes, I mean, think of it from a semantic
versioning perspective: Node gets to make
breaking changes it gets to say, "We've incremented
the major version number, we look at the change
log and upgrade."
Browsers don't, they just update every six
weeks, if you're lucky, every six months,
or not.
The users certainly don't get to look at the
change log.
From that perspective, browsers are always
on major version 1.0.
>> On the other hand, it doesn't upgrade on
a completely 100 per cent strict "you're not
going to see any changes that might break
things".
ES6 did make a whole bunch of changes that
did break things and browsers had to come
back and say look, we tried shipping this,
and it actually broke things in the way that
the committee didn't expect because the committee
didn't want to break things and it didn't
want to stay compatible, so there was a sort
of back and forth, and we arrived at a more
compatible version, but there are cases of
breakage that are very strange, like adding
method to arrays, is observed in some browsers
to break their users even if other browsers
don't find it can be breaking, so what actually
is a simpler version, a major change we can't
do is a little bit fuzzy.
>> Certainly, like and these are tiny changes.
We're not going to remove with "with" or "var"
or something.
JULIA: we will move over to one question from
the community which will take us into the
next, which is what as a panel or as people
are you doing to become more visible, and
better connected to the community?
>> I will take this one.
This speaks to how I actually got involved.
Last year, throughout Node and TC39's relationship,
there's never been a great relationship there.
They weren't talking to one another.
Here you had one of the most popular JavaScript
platforms, and there was no connection, no
communication going on with the community
or with the committee.
It really came to a head last year, it was
just a tonne of public arguing on Twitter
which is always great fun.
We came to realise if Node wanted to engage,
we needed actually to show up in the meetings,
get involved in the discussions, provide feedback
on the proposals as they were being proposed
- it's a novel concept.
It goes back to my own thing that would you
community involvement, it is not good.
We wanted to become involved.
It was literally a matter of just showing
up.
JULIA: so I think something that a lot of
people will be interested in is, like, what
as audience members, what can they do - also
myself - what can I look at?
What's a great place to start getting involved?
>> The standard is developed both in the in-person
meetings and also on GitHub.
It is developed with patches.
People can submit PRs.
We do have a number of community contributors
who are not committee members who do submit
DRs and get real spec changes and really help
us develop a lot of difficult details with
this specification.
So there is one main repository for the master
spec, and there are a bunch of smaller repositories
for the proposals which are not yet merged
into the main spec.
In these proposals, it's great if people file
bugs or add issues, or at comments to bugs
to give feedback on the proposals.
Some proposals are available in Babble or
cross-compilation environments, and you can
use them in your own code, and give feedback
to us based on that, especially if you can
do it in GitHub issues.
That's the most accessible way to propose
champions.
JULIA: so www.github.com/39.
>> this was been a - this has been a big change.
both in TC39, the spec used to be developed
in a Word document which the editor kept on
his computer and sent out to a mailing list
once a month, so having it a visible changeless
- where he can submit requests and issues,
it is pretty great.
there is a lot more we can do.
I hope that we are trying to meet you guys
where you are, and certainly where I like
to spend more of my day instead of my inbox.
>> one place that you can look at well is
TC39/agendas.
and, on agendas, you can find the agendas
of the next meetings, and this is a great
way to discover what language features are
actively being developed.
because there are lots of different repos,
it can be really hard to find a focus.
if you look in agendas, you can find that.
JULIA: there is so much that we want to talk
about.
I guess the best thing we can do now is [sound
cut] specifically to ask, then I believe we've
chosen a location to sit for a bit and take
your questions.
>> we will go to the - all of us will be at
community space afterwards.
there is stuff scheduled -
>>
Google booth.
JULIA: these wonderful folks will be there
to answer more questions.
there are lots of topics and questions about
diversity workers being done now.
the TC39 has been for around for a while but
pertinent discussions that are still happening.
make yourself - if you have questions, come
and ask, and feel free to get involved.
thank you.
[Applause].